Charlotte it has been a big year on the
Broadway stage and we're excited this
morning to bring you the nominations for
the top categories the 2017 Tony Awards
announcing the nominees are Tony winning
actress that's Jane Krakowski and
Christopher Jackson who was nominated
last year for his role in Hamilton that
they are approaching the podium take it
away you too good morning everyone and
welcome to the 2017 Tony Award
nominations we are coming to you live
from New York Public Library for the
performing arts at Lincoln Center in New
York City to announce the nominees for
the 71st annual Tony Awards and now for
this year's nominees the nominees for
Best Performance by an actor in a
leading role in a play are Denny aren't
Heisenberg Chris Cooper a doll's house
part two Corey Hawkins six degrees of
separation Kevin Kline present laughter
Jefferson Mays Oslo the nominees yes yes
the nominees for Best Performance by an
actress in a leading role in a play are
Cate Blanchett the present Jennifer L
Oslo Sally Field The Glass Menagerie
Laura Linney and Lillian Hellman's the
little foxes Laurie Metcalf a doll's
house part two
the nominees for Best Performance by an
actor in a leading role in a musical are
Christian Boyle
falsettos Josh Groban Natasha Pierre in
the great comet of 1812
Andy Carl groundhog day the musical
david Hyde Pierce Hello Dolly and Ben
Platt dear Evan Hanson the nominees for
Best Performance by an actress in a
leading role in a musical are Danai
Benton Natasha Pierre and the great
comet of 1812 christine ebersole
Warpaint Patti LuPone warpaint Bette
Midler Hello Dolly and Eva noble Zahra
Miss Saigon and Jane Krakowski oh wait
sorry I wasn't in anything sir the
nominees for Best revival of a play are
August Wilson's jitney Lillian Hellman's
the little foxes present laughter six
degrees of separation the nominees for
Best revival of a musical are falsettos
Hello Dolly and Miss Saigon the nominees
for Best Play are a doll's house part
two in decent Oslo sweat
[Applause]
the nominees for Best Musical are come
from away dear Evan Hansen Groundhog Day
the musical Natasha Pierre in the great
comet of 1812 there are a few more
nominations to get to this morning but
for all of you watching CBS this morning
we're going to send it back to Charlie
gale and Nora all right Thank You Kris
and Jane thank you guys thank you it was
very nice of them to it right back to us
actor playwright and CBS this morning
contributor like that actor playwright
I'll take it Jamie Wax joins us at the
table hello actor playwright hello so
last year Hamilton dominating 16
nominations do you think it's better for
the Tonys and Broadway when there isn't
a dominant play I gotta say I mean I've
been here at the table with you all
during these nominations for four years
now I've spent my life working in the
theater to me this is one of the most
exciting Broadway seasons ever last year
was the year of Hamilton it was the
dominant force there was some other good
work done but this year there is so much
good stuff in revivals in musicals in
new American plays there's really really
a lot to go around and I think the
awards this year in the nominations
reflect that
dear Evan Hansen yeah what a great show
I mean it's it's really kind of a
wonderful thing it's a show without any
sort of real stars as as producers
define them and it's just it just took
off and it's captured the imagination
not only of traditional theatre goers
but young people everywhere I mean it's
its original Broadway cast album has
done incredibly well on the charts
you know kids in Mississippi and
Oklahoma are listening to this music and
we reported on on some of the negative
presentations of teen suicide in the
media this is a really incredible show
in a way that it's touching lives and
allowing young people to talk to their
families been glad and Josh grobin
weren't competing I do talk to great
performing it's a tough category great
comet actually Natasha appear in the
great comet of 1812 is leading with 12
nominations this year dear Ivan Hansen
next with 9 best revival of play August
Wilson jitney yes Lillian Hellman's
little foxes present laughter and six
degrees
all great great classics jitney
especially was phenomenal in the fact
that it had an entirely african-american
creative team end cast it's the only one
of that cycle that August Wilson wrote
that has not played Broadway before that
and I'm glad to see it recognized
because it is one of the plays that has
closed some odd days I did see one
before the the Broadway show
before the Broadway nominate Tony's Tom
sinker what would that one be I would
have to see Evan Hanson I think someone
should see or the great comet of 1812
all right thank you thank you so much I
want to see and we will learn this
year's winners at the 71st annual Tony
Awards Tony winning actor that's Kevin
Spacey will be the host this year you
can watch the awards Sunday June 11th at
8:00 7:00 central right here on CBS